foreign
[Music]
or if you're our new alien overlords who
apparently we just found out about
yesterday I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report we are at the local studio
in Miami I told you guys I was going off
the grid we did our big Off the Grid
Bonanza show but then yesterday I got a
text from this guy America's mayor Rudy
Giuliani said I'm coming to Miami can
you sit down with me and I said Mr Mayor
I will delay my vacation wow for a
couple hours for you how you doing my
friend have a great vacation but yeah
you deserve it well let's see if you can
send me off instead I will uh first off
it's great to see you we did the Patrick
Podcast weeks ago I enjoyed that I got
so much feedback on that wow we battled
politically they wanted us to battle but
in a way people like it yeah we did it
like the old-fashioned way and that's
strange I mean without getting angry at
each other but really intense are you
telling me there was once a time when
people could disagree about politics and
yeah I want to kill each other they
might break bread and sit down we're
actually at one time rational
it was a long time ago all right well
I'm always thrilled to sit down with you
and uh and everyone knows I I most of my
formative years I spent in New York City
when you were the mayor and I was there
for 9 11 and just you're I wrote about
you in my book because you've just done
so many incredible things but I thought
for two well for however long you want
to do it up top you want to get into any
of this legal nonsense sure whatever you
want to ask it's always worth uh
clarifying it because there are some
people that forget that most of what
they get from 80 of the media is
nowadays not even um oh 80 you're being
nice so I am being you are being nice
yeah it used to be kind of warped
now it's flat out false and untrue yeah
so the latest one is
I uh admitted that I lied about the two
women in Atlanta who were on a video uh
appearing to be taking ballots out of a
out of a box that was under a under a
big blanket and they had gotten rid of
all the Republicans and they were
furiously counting ballots and they were
alleged to be involved in violating the
law because in in Georgia you have to
have a person present when you do that
and you can see them on the on the video
throwing everybody out right so this was
the video that everyone kind of so they
sued me they sued me and they alleged
that I'm lying about that
that I that the words are false that I
have intent
uh and that they can violate my first
amendment privilege because it's so so
bad what I what I said
so uh in order in order to
get to the heart of the case we've made
a stipulation which is very common in
the law we concede for the purposes of
the case
that first allegation that it was untrue
we don't admit it we don't deny it we
just put it aside and say it doesn't
matter if it's true or false because we
have such a strong and winning case on
lack of intent
and on our first amendment defenses
second reason that first part would be
tried before a Atlanta I'm sorry A
Washington jury and my chances of
winning before Washington jury or not
right right so we get the Washington
jury unfairness out so now the Press
says Giuliani admits lying you look at
the document carefully it says this is
just for the purpose of that case it's
not an admission of lying it's not
contesting it and I can't contest lying
anyplace else in the world but they
don't bother to read the rest of it yeah
and and something like this of course as
a lawyer for 50 years I've probably done
500 times and it's well known in the war
it's a stipulation where you don't
admitted deny so that you don't have to
fight over this part of the case even
though you think you might win it might
take you so long cause you so much money
when you can win on this part of the
case much faster and much cheaper right
so pardon my legal naivete for a moment
so what so what do you want to happen
next now so well
the public perception of what happened
well this will permit me to not have to
go through a big long trial
and we will get to a legal decision on
in ho and trying to hold me responsible
for defamation aren't they violating My
First Amendment rights my rights to
represent my client and have that
position as a lawyer true or false see
true or false right I don't have to get
into proving that it was false which
would take a long time meaning just just
to clarify so you have the right to free
speech of course and you as a lawyer
have a right to defend because even
beyond that right regardless of whether
what they're saying is right or wrong or
anything and we think if we get it out
of the biased uh DC district and we get
it up to the more
uh General
um legal principles are applied in the
DC circuit and I also think we got a
chance to go to the Supreme Court
because it is a perfect example of the
censorship that's going on now because I
was being censored so we want to get it
on a fast track there so when you do
that you make stipulations
so we made the stipulation the lawyers
did it in the language it's been a
hundred times never interpreted that way
and of course the fake media immediately
says joy only admits that he's lying
well yeah I mean I'm not lying I didn't
admit it
uh I don't even admit it for that case I
just didn't contest it and I have to
tell you I'm proud of myself I woke up
this morning I saw it in the newspapers
I put it down and I went back to sleep
well the funny thing is that I saw I
think we texted and then literally it
was like five minutes later I see the
headline what I'm trying and I'm like uh
I'm trying to go off for August why do I
why am I getting but then I was like
wait why am I believing anything of
course the media and of course it's a
perfect day to run this because Hunter
Biden is totally falling apart and they
always look for something now if
something even better comes along where
they can try to bury it they'll take me
out of them the aliens we got
non-biological humans or something crash
it's very exciting and we got something
that can't surprise you I mean a lot of
New York City most of your life aliens
like I saw Men in Black come on I I
think I've met them
you probably and in fact some of them
might do a better job in the White House
well that I have no doubt about that
anything else you want to say just about
the last couple years of like just the
hate no but but I'd rather get into your
career and yeah I would I would like to
say about the last couple of years that
we can't laugh about it this is
extremely serious and when uh some of
the candidates uh tell you that this
election is truly about saving America
they're right
if we don't get this next election right
we officially become a fascist country
if we aren't that right now so how
worried are you that because so much of
the but because so much of the what
happens electorally is left to the
states that certain States like Florida
where we are we have airtight elections
I think I told you this when I saw you
it was such a pleasure to vote here show
my ID have them match it walk to the Box
a guy standing there get a piece of
paper put like it was so perfect and
contrast that with Los Angeles where I
walked in I tried to show my ID just out
of force a habit the guy goes like this
so how worried are you that no matter
what we do right in certain states that
the three or four states that are purple
or blue that really matter it just won't
make a difference
very
in fact I think
at this point anything can change that
would be the only way we lose and now
I'm not just talking about my candidate
uh Trump or DeSantis or who knows Tim
Scott or
I'm talking about Republicans will win
this election
because there's more to come out and now
the flood gates have opened I don't see
how they close it now you're talking
about Hunter yeah and the laptop I've
been wrong in the past because I thought
some of the revelations in the past
which is like when I got the hard drive
because I was the only one who had it
right does that seem insane to you I
said to myself with this thing this
election's over the selection's over and
of course they did something I could
never I don't think anybody anticipated
they did a total censorship
on a piece of evidence that the FBI had
validated eight months before
the FBI let that go on and didn't
intervene the FBI watched Joe Biden go
on National Television during a debate
and say that Donald Trump and me Rudolph
Giuliani were Russian Pawns they knew it
wasn't true
eight months earlier they knew it wasn't
true and they did nothing to correct it
I mean that is about as frightening as
it gets on top of the collusion with big
dogs if you get to collusion with big
Tech the paid for Russian uh collusion
allegations Hillary by the by this point
they knew that Hillary paid 1.1 million
dollars I mean that's right a play right
how do you think of a story I do want to
get into some of your past history which
I think LED you to being able to do
these fights and wake up every morning
and read something stupid and then go
back to sleep but it it must do
something to you it must upset you at
some level it does personally in that in
that if we were if someone said Rudy
Giuliani in 2003 in America you were
loved by everybody and now they have
framed it I know plenty of people that
love yeah I love you I know what you did
for that City and for this country but
they've you know created a caricature
that is disconnected from from the
person that I know
I don't know how to describe this best
David most of the time it doesn't bother
me like today today was a good day I
said Lord I almost laughed at it
some days some little thing that they
misrepresent about me will get me all
upset yeah and I will get into what
normal people do which is maybe they'll
never get over it maybe this will be my
real Legacy
and then after a while I think about it
and I think about the bigger picture
and I think about the fact that I've
been true to myself
and think about the fact that my father
would be proud of me
and I say that's more important that's
eventually going to win out if it isn't
here it'll be in heaven yeah and and I
do feel proud that I'm doing the right
thing for my country I'm also proud of
the fact
that if it wasn't for me none of this
would be out when I listen to them
debate this I sometimes say to myself
wow they would have known none of this
yeah if I didn't put out the original
information way back in
2019 early 2019 when I went on Hannity
Show
and went to John Solomon and said look
what I have I have a bribe the one we're
talking about now yeah I have a bribe
from my callus oshevski to Joe Biden
would you believe he's a crook and I
produced the witnesses
you go back to my third podcast it's a
live interview with Mr shoken
you don't have to go through all these
Shenanigans you got the prosecutor
telling you he fired me
of course I was going after the the
company and his son which Biden has
basically admitted to while he was VP
right right except he did it because the
guy was corrupt right right there is no
evidence in the file that he's corrupt
and the Press very very corruptly avoids
a actual recording
between poroshenko and Biden in which
poroshenko tells Biden that he's going
to have to make up the corruption
and you know that Biden approves the new
prosecutor
how does Biden get to approve the new
prosecutor how does the president vice
president approve the new prosecutor if
he isn't involved in a corrupt scheme to
make sure the case is dismissed also I'm
fairly certain I'd have to check in the
Constitution our vice president doesn't
have the real authority to be deciding
who prosecutors are in other countries
or even in America
right exactly or even in America I guess
maybe a little bit with the attorney
general he can offer some insight
but are you worried that no matter how
like after the years of this or the
lines the more lies and censorship that
you will swim and you'll swim upstream
and the Machine just has a way of
convincing people that up is down and
left is right and two plus two is five
yeah I am worried about that sure two
two very odd things happen here one good
and one bad I guess one is I would say I
could locate maybe five instances in
which we've either I've come across or
somebody else has a piece of information
that at any other time and any other
place in American history would have
destroyed a candidate and all of us
sitting around people like Steve Bannon
and uh uh people like Dan bongino and
people like you and people people who
are knowledgeable would say wow this is
over and this is over and it wasn't over
right yeah or on the other hand we would
have looked at Trump and said he did
something either correctly interpreted
or incorrectly interpreted or
exaggerated or we would have said it's
over
like after January 6th right everybody
thought well he'll never he may he may
resurrect some of his reputation because
it's probably exaggerated somewhat
they'll never be able to run again
now he's leading everybody right do you
find him so you know I I supported him
and I've interviewed him and I'm friends
with the kids and and I like him I
happen to love DeSantis right now what's
going on here in Florida of course which
we already did that game and we can talk
about a little bit if you want
um do you find just in terms of being
legal counsel for him that because of
his I'll say anything at any time and
does that make you pull out some of the
hair that's left
they used to be here there before uh I
did all the point of hair that I can do
yeah and at this point
um
I'm convinced that you have to let them
do it because he is a strange situation
that I guess a lot of people accept that
some don't
he actually is an innocent man who's
being falsely accused and the
frustration now having gone through a
little of that myself yeah not at the
level that he has but they went after me
for two years uh took all my documents
took my iCloud account without telling
me listen to three years of my
conversation about am I knowing it
uh it does produce
a certain
reaction that nobody's going to have
until they go through it yeah so I think
so I give him the benefit of the doubt I
also have seen
how somehow what he does works out
and said maybe he's wiser than we are I
don't know
and maybe that's what produces the
personality well you can't get them down
maybe there's certain things you have to
do to have that kind of personality
because this man should be crushed
uh if you if you if you were any other
man right uh the things they've done to
him are and by the way I have nothing
but admiration for that they're unreal
you know when I when I interviewed him I
asked him about this and it probably
relates to a little bit of your
trajectory as well but when I would
watch and I remember watching these
things in the late 80s 90s watching him
on Phil Donahue or watching him on Oprah
you know his affect was very soft there
was a very pleasant way of doing
everything and it's like a warmth and
everything else right from the times
I've met him yes uh but then I think the
machine hits you so hard you start
becoming more Gruff you start becoming
whatever and and then I think that leads
to this so I do give him a Long Leash on
that I would say it's sort of like you
you were on Seinfeld my favorite sitcom
of all time in what 1994 94. bro you
weren't even there yet they were the
morning after I was elected is that
right I had no sleep so you know right
because the episode it was and it was
going to be either or Bloomberg the way
the way uh the way he did it he he had
that written in for whoever the mayor
was wait you were Bloomberg
excuse me David Dinkins David is either
me or David Dinkins right thank God it
wasn't yeah yeah you really yeah there
were a lot of Rubens that lived in New
York City those years they've all since
fled they stayed for you and then got
out but but my point is that that
someone like you you were on Seinfeld
the number one sitcom in the country in
1994 and it's like they would Hollywood
would not do something with you now and
it's the same thing with Trump he was in
Home Alone too and now they edited his
senile when they put it on how about I I
hosted Saturday Night Live I was on
Saturday nine times nine times and I
hosted my own show
it's crazy now if they put me on they
they'll get fired that'd be it that'd be
it so all right so let's let's move on
some from some of the legal stuff um
we're here in Florida you're sort of
part-time Florida New York yeah right
right I have I have a condo in Florida
and I come down as much as I can Which
is less than I'd like but I love it here
are you kind of Blown Away at the
comparison between the two places right
now it's really ridiculous I mean
there's no comparison between uh how
much nicer it is here and during the
pandemic is what really did it yeah I
mean in New York you felt like you were
in some form of East brilliant
including right to the point of from the
old Nazi movies do you have Peppers you
cannot come in here without your pets
literally yeah here you walk in I'm
walking around for my papers like I
would say you did come on in
oh wow we're in America again uh luckily
we didn't put our life at risk by coming
across the border like you did between
East and West Berlin right but I mean it
that I think for New Yorkers
particularly and that's why so many of
the people that come here in New orgas
that was like a
it was like a mind blower I mean it just
but here we are in in oppression and
here we are in pretty much an open
society and they're losing less people
than we are something's wrong here were
you in New York City during so you were
basically there for all of us for most
of it I couldn't get out and that's how
I started my podcast that's how I
started my radio show I started my
podcast on my own really on a thought
that I wanted to have one going for 2020
when Trump was running and then John
castamatides took over ABC who's been a
friend of mine for years and asked me if
I wouldn't do a pandemic show so my
original radio show with Dr Maria was
about the pandemic or she was an expert
on it and then it spread out into
everything else
so you're in New York City we have our
Summer of Love riots everything else and
which shocks the hell out of me because
I was a mayor who took over a city that
had had two major rides including a
pogrom yeah and I vowed
no right
I put a whole program in place that I
borrowed really from a report that was
done for Governor Cuomo put a whole
program in place on how to prevent a
riot
since today we put that program in
effect
there's been no riots
until then
so no riots on any Republican mayor
first right under a Democrat mayor and
we go 20 years with that one what were
some of the things that were the first
the most important one is the thing they
violated right from the beginning you
you deal with the riot
if you can't even before it starts so
the idea is
when the guy throws the first rock
arrest him
the Dinkins idea was cooling off period
let him throw a couple of rocks if you
arrest him you're going to create the
ride let him bang up a couple of cars
maybe even bang up a couple of people
but don't show Too Much police presence
and don't get involved early because
you'll make the riot worse my theory
based on thousands of years of
criminology and having been in the field
for 40 years it is
you deal with the smallest possible act
and it doesn't escalate you show them
you're serious and that's it so the guy
throws the rock arrest him off
next guy breaks the window arrest him
off third guy spits at a cop off he
riots over
I've never had one I did that
30 times never had a ride and of course
people said you were mean
I also would have the city was
flourishing and I would have and I had
no fear of having cops in riot gear
because uh the cops and riot gear do not
create riots
cops and riot gear scare the living
deadlights out of the Riders
and they tell you we're gonna be serious
yeah we're not fooling around with you
and uh I'm not doing that to be nasty to
the rioters I'm doing that to save the
property of all those innocent people
that are right behind them who lost
billions of dollars in property 27 lives
and nobody's been prosecuted for that
meanwhile they torture the January six
people and literally torture them and
they killed nobody in fact they got
killed all right yeah
so what would you do right now in New
York we've talked about this a little
bit but I think it's worth repeating
because New York I go back now
go to Midtown it's sad it's depressing
smells like weed everywhere I'm not
again I'm for basically for legalization
of marijuana but but just the there's no
business people anymore it's everybody's
wandering around in a hoodie nobody
there's no people dogs with any dogs are
dying of drugs yeah because there's so
much drugs they're left on the ground
and the dog licks it up and the dog gets
a seizure I mean Seventh Avenue by uh
you know below 42nd right which was the
the Fashion District it's just there's
just crack at it you know what happened
New York City combined two things so
maybe three things where it is very weak
all Democratic cities are first of all
they tried to put together a very
complex system
please notice anytime Democrats try to
put together a complex system they fail
because they can't manage their idea
idealist idea ideologically oriented
it's like when Obama Started Obamacare
remember the computer went down for
three months right it sounds good
they don't concentrate on things like
that yeah so they were going to set up
legal
very well inspected centers for legal
marijuana with a limit on the amount of
marijuana
and a certain amount of a certain amount
of uh of uh vetting as to who gets it so
you're not giving it to addicts
they took so long fighting over how to
do that about three years that over one
thousand illegal shops set up
in between
the people
are half in confusion as to whether it's
legal or Rich it is legal but you can
only buy it from a from a state store
even though now if you go to New York
City the shops are all over the shop but
they don't you don't know what they're
selling it illegally right right there
are only eight legal ones there were 1
200 illegal ones wow so look who's
winning second in those illegal ones
nowadays a new thing happened they
didn't anticipate that
you go into one of those shops you're
taking your life in aunt they don't even
know they're giving you fentanyl it
could be slipped into marijuana it could
be slipped in people people like to buy
uh
off the counter or illegal uh percocet
or oxycodone or
they think they're getting a
prescription drug they shouldn't be
using it but still they don't think
they're using Fentanyl and boom they're
dead so we have a disaster now uh we
have an epidemic of drug use at this
point and
um it's not so much that we legalized
heroin we completely ineffectively
inefficiently grossly negligently
implemented it so there's almost no way
we're gonna the 1200 illegal stores are
going to be overwhelmed by the
20 legal stores and it's just
mind-blowing that they do it over and
over and over again they need only look
at San Francisco to see what the future
of New York is and yet they they still
do it right we went from de Blasio to
Eric Adams I mean they in essence just
said okay A little I guess he's a little
less crazy he's not a I think de Blasio
is actually a communist I don't know if
Eric Adams is Adams has the right ideas
and doesn't know how to implement them
yeah he's got the right ideas and two
things prevent him from everybody one is
he gets frightened by the by the lefties
they can intimidate him and number two
he
he's just not a manager he doesn't have
the talent of being able to execute or
think things through like how do I get
those licenses out faster they also
decided they wanted to give the license
for legal distribution to ex addicts
they thought that was a nice symbolic
gesture right right but now you got to
check the background of all these
addicts it takes a year
and I'm not not so sure the best thing
to do was to give it to ex addicts
addicts ex-addicts are wonderful if they
remain ex but half of them go back so
because I know you have your your
conservative in certain senses obviously
you're a Republican and at one time
we're running was running for president
as a Republican and you were mayor as a
republican but I know you have some
libertarian beliefs as well you're
you're a little more liberal in certain
things in terms of marijuana then what I
don't want to get too lost in this but
like what would your policy be if you
were mayor now and you see that there's
this problem with this you want people
to be able to wow individual autonomy
how do you balance those things yeah I
think you know eight million people so
now we're not in a perfect world anymore
could you have started this right and
make it work yeah you could have uh you
would have to have invested in
enforcement you'd have to keep the mob
out you'd have to keep you'd have to
have put in
oh gosh like we did for um private
carting private carting with control by
the by the Mafia took a lot to get them
we put a commission in effect we checked
everybody and now it works seamlessly
letting the illegals take over
you almost have to start over again yeah
you'd have to make it illegal again get
rid of all of them and then start a new
system do you think there's enough I
don't know if this is the word I don't
want to say good people but do you think
there's enough true New Yorkers in the
sense that you and I know what that
means to fix what's going on there like
there I don't see another Rudy Giuliani
that's going to do it at a political
level or even the people there anymore
they you go to New York it doesn't feel
like what what we know New York was
I don't think that's a question we can
answer until somebody tries to answer it
because if that same question were asked
in 1984 85 86 a lot of people would have
said a lot of people have tried nobody
succeeded it doesn't work
um
my answer is and probably because I
still am an idealist yes
there is a conceivable person
and then change of opinion on the part
of New Yorkers that could bring it about
now a bit of good news you look at the
last
uh gubernatorial all action even the
last mayoral election where Adams beat
Curtis Sliwa Curtis did much better than
the usual Republican probably as well as
anyone since Bloomberg when he was a
republican he was a republican right uh
zeldin who ran against my son in the
primary that was a good primary if we
didn't take 500 that thousand sane New
Yorkers to Florida he might have done it
yeah but zeldon ran a race where what
was he five off yeah five offs not bad
plus we won all of Long Island
so yeah I do see
I see the state possibly changing
I would not
initially give up on New York for a
republican candidate this time wouldn't
put it on a top list but I wouldn't put
it where we usually put it which is pay
no attention to it watch it for a while
because it almost elected a republican
Governor yeah
um if you could get New York back the
state back
you could start creating the groundwork
for getting the city back so no it's not
impossible but very very hard and a long
shot how do you feel personally when
you're walking around now where you know
you once were the hero of the city I
mean I will never it is so ingrained in
me those days in 9 11 and I lived up by
Gracie Mansion at the time I was on 90th
and York
um and just what you basically saved
that City and in some ways the country
truly
um walking around then and the aftermath
of that versus walking around it's very
personal and I feel my if I let myself
think about it my heart is broken when I
when I see it
um I keep hoping it's going to change I
keep looking for things that will change
it half the time I'm really disappointed
and I'm in the mindset you you asked me
about before I don't think it can be
done and then the other half I start
thinking rationally and I start thinking
about how different things can be put
together I look at what we did in the
last gubernatorial race the last mayor's
race I see the people getting so upset
I mean they're so so upset
um
but the Democrats have done such a good
job of brainwashing yeah it's
frightening so I take a look at Chicago
my goodness Chicago 55 years of
democratic rule
they just had a choice between a very
very left and a left but somewhat
moderate mayor
they go with the very very left mayor
after being destroyed by a very left May
who they threw out of office and now
last weekend 33 shootings and five
murders which wasn't a bad weekend trip
it's a running joke on our show sadly
where I asked the guys we take we I
guess basically how many people shot and
killed but it's never covered on
mainstream media because of course it
doesn't and please realize they're
mostly black people yeah uh internet
Administration run by blacks
which makes you wonder and and black
lives matter is located there they don't
give a damn
I mean it's all about their making money
being powerful does that also drive you
nuts how how everything's still in 2023
from a certain set of people is so
racial when you were mayor of the most
diverse in the good sense of diverse
where everybody you know whether we
loved each other or not we were I always
think like if you went on a sub it's now
1997 you're on the subway in New York
City everybody from planet Earth is on
that Subway and maybe some people not
from planet Earth and we're not killing
each other and that so New York was what
America is really supposed to be yeah
you know
I one of these days I've got to have a
camera with me for two or three days
just walk down the city I think people
would be shocked by the number of
minorities that come up and thank me
uh I think they think in New York I must
be very unpopular if I go to a
democratic City I'm very unpopular not
New York not New York New York I get a
little bit but I get much more of we
want you back we don't care if you some
of them will come up to me and say it
usually starts this way
we used to love you you were a great
mayor great prosecutor
I always know what's going to happen and
then you supported Trump
now I get a final part of the chapter
and we forgive you oh oh that's nice
because we need you back right
we need you back and they'll say we
don't care about Trump anymore we need
you back my God could you come back
would you ever do it
would you ever do anything to do it and
black people I don't even go through
that thing they come up to me and say
thank you for getting me a job and we we
got
uh jobs of 500 000 people
and got them off we call the work Fair
which we should have right now
uh best thing you can do is get him a
job I get people that come up to me
three four times a week thanking me for
getting them a job and that
that makes up for some of the depression
would you ever do it could they I Never
Say Never I think it would be very very
unlikely yeah it would be very unlikely
right you got a nice the only thing got
a nice place think about it that tempts
me is
I watch this stuff and I know it isn't
as hard to do as they're making it no
it's not easy but it's not as hard to do
as they're making it do you think the
hardest part is just having the will to
do it sort of that which is sort of gets
back to what we were talking about with
Trump before it's just like the will to
say this is how we are going to do it
and then just and sticking with it and
not paying attention to the know-it-alls
uh
they used to be just know-it-alls now
they're worse now that now I I think
they're part of an ideology almost part
of a conspiracy in the Press when you
watch the way in which they censored and
that was highly organized I mean I I
don't I don't know how close and then
when I used to notice this when I
represented Trump in the impeachment
proceedings every day they leaked
something
you'd listen to the shows and it all say
precisely the same same words it was
like to have a reading from the same uh
playlist that was put out by the
uh the the bureau yeah the Biden Bureau
or the or the uh or the Democratic
Bureau you know the report's been
debunked the report's been debunked
support's been debunked
uh
Biden knew nothing about his son's
foreign dealings but I knew nothing
about his son's foreign dealing now it's
become Biden wasn't in business with his
son well the other line that Biden keeps
saying which I think is shows like the
craziest level of all this is when Biden
has repeatedly said he's never discussed
business business with his son
as a father what an insane statement
that he never discussed he had no idea
what his son was doing for a living but
no freaking idea it's incredible like
when you hear that you must yeah and
there is and when when they really do
that a lot uh Ted Knights had Ted works
with me on um on America's mayor alive
we we found this beautiful tape in which
uh Joe calls up Hunter and leaves a text
message
and he explains to him that he just read
the New York Times article oh and
Biden's about hunter's foreign dealings
yeah and don't worry you're in the clear
right which means he has just read all
about the foreign dealings he knows
nothing about it
and it does actually sound like
something out of the mafia tapes when he
says and you're in the clear who says
you're in the clear and you don't you
know a little something about it I think
I could take Fat Tony and put it next to
it he probably said a few times don't
worry Rocco you're in the clear do you
think back on fighting the mafia guys
before you were there in some ways is
like the good old days compared to the
thing you're fighting now I'm gonna tell
you that we're better fathers
I
think Fat Tony would not have disowned
his granddaughter
he would have been ashamed of himself
for doing that I mean I when that was
the coup de gras for me on Biden who I
knew for 35 years
it's just an amiable dope
when I first found out he was a crook I
was really disappointed
when I found out what a big crook is I
was shocked and said something has to be
done or you can't allow this in America
or otherwise it's going to happen again
and now what I see what a cruel Manny is
that's a heart that and that is his
grandfather thing is so important well
it's the same narcissism that got him to
take his
uh uh delicate son
and he had two sons right obviously it
looks like Bo was was the real thing
strong guy the other guy looks like he
was uh wounded
uh addictive personality when he's 17.
you take that guy and you put him in
business with the biggest criminals in
the world
to protect you
you just made him a degenerate drug
addict he has no chance of overcoming
drug addiction working with Whitey
bulge's nephew uh Michaelis oshevski
biggest crooked Ukraine uh the worst spy
in China
uh the Crooked mayor's wife where they
get 3.5 million dollars in a turkey the
crook in Romania the guy is working with
some of the worst people in the world
and he's got an indeed he's got an
affliction
and if you love him
you go get him a job in a college
right yeah and he's selling he's selling
art for nine hundred thousand dollars a
pop art that of course is the easiest
way to money launder of course no you
know you create those complications and
if you listen to the to the tape
recordings and the look at the video
messages and everything you see a very
troubled guy I mean the LA the most
valuable tape is one that combines
everything it's in
December of 2018 turned it to his
daughter and he's warning his daughter
about getting involved as a bag man and
he says I know they're trying to get you
in and you put up with them better than
I do
but for 30 years
I've been paying for all of the expenses
of this family and they still don't
respect me
and even with that for 30 years pop has
required me to give him half my income
now you got two things there right you
got the bitterness right but you just
got the admission of a RICO case
why would any son give half his income
for 30 years to his father except it was
his father's income
wouldn't they just have to look at Joe's
tax returns at this point how he became
how about the bank account they've never
subpoenaed his bank account yeah so so
the minute I see as a prosecutor I paid
for all the expenses of the family
I go subpoena all the mortgages
I go subpoena all the credit cards
and I create a I work with the honest
IRS and we create a big Ledger of how
much he paid for how much did Hunter pay
for for Joe
and how does that equate with the pride
money he was getting
and you have on one side of The Ledger
the money is being paid for Hunter for
no reason
having to do with Hunter I mean China
didn't pay 31 million dollars to a
degenerate drug addict so he could buy
coke right they had another purpose
there and now you've seen the money
flowing to me you figure out the purpose
and then with China you can put down a
list of all the favors that Joe did for
China
gee would somebody have done this just
for the heck of giving up the Grom Air
Base 400 miles from China
I don't think anybody any patriotic
American
would have given up that air base I
think you'd have to have killed me to
give up that air base 400 miles from
China when we know that China may
possibly go to war with us one day and
we're right on their back door and can
bomb The Living Daylights I don't know
if they have to and we give it up
all right let's uh we could clearly do
that all day long but let's spend our
last remaining time I just want to talk
about leadership because again as you
know I was in New York during 9 11 I was
21 years old
um it was formative for me it was formed
a few but I remember being in that City
and just watching you we've discussed
this before but that the only thing that
felt sane basically was that you were
out there and doing that and I think
your career and fighting the mob before
that all that obviously led to it
what level of um
were you ready like when you when you
realized what was going what was
happening on September 11th yeah not
ready for it but did you feel I'm
supposed to be here right you know what
I'm supposed to do this
the first reaction to how bad it was
originally I was told it was a
twin-engine plane that hit the North
Tower and I rushed down there second
plane hit I knew it was a terrorist
attack and then I got right below the
tower
rushing up to the fire department
command post and I saw a man jump
and that was like a change of everything
I said to myself oh my God this is way
above us and I grabbed Bernie Carrick my
Police Commissioner and I said Bernie
this is way off the charts
we don't have a plan for this we're just
going to have to go with our instincts
and pray to God we make the right
decision because we had like 27 plans
for emergencies we were like obsessive
on com on doing it because we had been
bombed in 93 right and uh no one plan
fit airplanes being used as missiles but
quickly I realized that from doing all
those plans we were much better prepared
than I thought and eventually I got to
the point where I felt like
by no means were we perfectly prepared
by no means do we do it perfectly but it
was good that we were the ones there
because we probably knew it better than
anybody else how aware were you that
there were cameras with you and that you
had to maintain a certain layer of
confidence because that's what it was
for the city that everyone I just
assumed because they were they were
basically you were I remember you going
down the street mobs of people around
you I remember Carrick there and you
were very you were always focused and
come there was no sense of like oh this
guy doesn't know what he's doing as
we're literally thinking that you know
there's more 100 aware of that 100 aware
of the fact that people were going to
watch me and they were going to react
based on how I reacted and when I would
find out that a good friend of mine or
pretty close to a best friend of mine
had just died I would say to myself I'm
gonna think about that tomorrow
and I remember uh being told about
Father Judge being dead the first one
and I could feel tears coming up and I
said to myself not today
not today only breaking that was uh at
the first or second press conference
after we finished
um one of the reporters
uh Marcia asked me
did you hear the tape of the woman on
the plane going into the Pentagon
talking to her husband about their
slitting for people's sitting throats
she was talking to the solicitor general
and I said right who was on the plane
and I said do you mean Ted Olson's wife
Barbara she said yes I said oh
I went behind Pataki
and I stopped I let him do the rest and
a couple of tears came in my eyes I just
seen him three days before
Ted was my close friend
she was a close friend
I was helping her promote a book about
about how terrible Hillary Clinton was
and she had just been in New York for a
bunch of interviews about the book which
was the best seller already
and she was
um
she was a quintessential
just Lively happy smart person and Ted
of course the guy who argued the bush V
Gore case just one of one of the great
lawyers and he and I did he and I did
the air traffic controllers together as
lawyers we were partners for Ronald
Reagan we did a whole bunch of things
together and we're very close friends
socially and
uh went to concerts together
you know why that hit me worse it came
out of nowhere
when I heard Father Judge I expected it
I knew I was going to lose 30 friends
40. I knew probably could have told you
where in the building they were my my
assistant for 30 years lost her husband
I conducted their wedding two years
earlier and you probably knew dozens of
the police officers at least had a face
because they loved you the head of the
head of uh
the head of search and rescue I had just
given him a going away party at Gracie
Mansion with him and 200 people his
family got to know his whole family no
these were my special people I would go
go to their
football games there hockey games try to
get him out of trouble when they start
fighting the police in the fire at the
hockey games we got to talk we all got
tossed out of Madison yeah I mean these
are my guys my people yeah
um
and I could see their cars when I was
standing there and I knew who like um
I knew who they were based on their
police car or fire car I knew they were
in the building
and I knew the kind of guys they were
when we gave the order to evacuate I
knew they were going to say
we'll evacuate when the civilians are
off the floor because they were
criticized for not responding
immediately but if such a naive thing to
think of right they're on a floor
they're 100 people on the floor we say
evacuate and they run away they run away
I mean what the hell kind of firefighter
is that my guys are going to wait until
everybody's off the floor those are the
ones who survived the ones who died
uh they were remarkable remarkable
people remarkable people the level of
Courage
unmatched
and somehow even though it's a great
tragedy that feeling of Courage
Elevate you yeah well that camaraderie
that the city has elevator that makes
you feel like there's a standard you
have to reach and I guess that's another
reason why I don't care what they do to
me as long as I help save my country
it doesn't matter I mean if I could if I
can if I can get out what I know
about how they've corrupted this country
and it turns that around it'd be worth
whatever they do to me
Mr Mayor I don't know that I could
possibly and a show better than that and
as my last thing before I go off the
grid what a pleasure to be with you as
always and I thank you well for me too
you're terrific question all the time
listen stay in Florida
great operation here too thanks
[Music]